bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8 l'actu
sur tv fil 78 temps ce 11 juin il est 18
heures si vous nous rejoignez en direct
et voici l les principaux titres journée
noire dans les transports 1 train sur 3
à la sncf en raison d'un mouvement de
grève contre le projet de loi sur la
réforme ferroviaire qui sera présenté la
semaine prochaine pour les taxis c'est
la concurrence des véhicules de tourisme
avec chauffeur qui coince une nouvelle
fois la maison léon blum à jouy en josas
devient maisons des illustres cela
devrait permettre au site de voir
s'accélérer son projet de faire revivre
l'histoire de la vie l'oeuvre littéraire
de l'ancien chef du gouvernement 10e
anniversaire du forum santé de lits ps
l'institut de promotion de la santé
jusqu'au 14 juin elle des professionnels
à votre rencontre à l'espace 50 ans à
montigny le bretonneux
nous en parlerons avec nos invités il
sera aussi question de la politique en
matière de santé de la nouvelle équipe
dirigeante de l'agglomération
la ville de trappes qui prépare sa fête
annuelle des 14 et 15 juin au stade
grave au thème de cette année l'espace
et une flash mob autour de la danse du
robot qui est prévue la chorégraphie que
vous voyez à l'image est disponible
intégralement sur le site de la ville
depuis le début de la semaine pour que
chacun puisse entraîner un danseur
professionnel vous enseignent les pas à
mémoriser en vue des performances du
samedi à 15h30 et 18h et du dimanche à
15h et 18h30 dans le reste du programme
de cette fête de la ville voyage dans
l'espace avec la fabrication de fusées
ou encore des défis des lois de la
pesanteur avec initiation aux échasses
urbaines des spectacles sont également
proposé un rendez vous 14 et 15 juin à
trappes spectacle de son et lumière à
partir de 23 heures
l'actualité du jour beaucoup moins
festif pour les salariés qui devaient
utiliser les transports en commun depuis
mardi soir 18h à la grève à la sncf a
fortement perturbé les déplacements de 1
train sur 2 à 1 train sur 3 ha selon les
lignes
une grève à l'appel de la sein de
l'intersyndicale cgt sud rail qui
contestent la future réforme ferroviaire
qui prévoit de regrouper sncf et réseau
ferré de france mais prévoit aussi de
réduire la dette de la société en
demandant une meilleure productivité aux
employés olivier maniscalco jonathan
wiedemann font le point sur la situation
dans le départ
je devais aller dans le 95 et comme
d'habitude
j'avais 30 et c'est chiant parce que du
coup ça ajoute une larme sur les
transports moi j'ai eu je vais avoir une
demi heure de retard là donc pour moi ça
change pas grand chose mais c'est c'est
dommage pour certains un autre visage et
je conçois qu'il prépare à cet endroit
c'est normal mais à force de faire trop
grève ça tue la grève la plus d'impact
donc les gens qu'est ce qu'ils en ont
marre comme ses usagers un peu désabusés
ils étaient nombreuses ce matin à
prendre leur mal en patience sur les
quais de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines où seulement un train sur trois
circulait en moyenne aujourd'hui les
cheminots de la sncf ont en effet lancé
un nouveau mouvement de grève au niveau
national pour protester contre la
réforme ferroviaire qui sera débattu à
l'assemblée dès le 17 juin
des actions symboliques ont même été
menés à la gare de versailles chantiers
où une trentaine de grévistes ont
investi le poste d'aiguillage pour
tenter de perturber le trafic
les syndicats réclament aujourd'hui le
retrait immédiat de la réforme pour le
gouvernement entendrait privatiser les
chemins de fer français
et de fait diminuer leurs avantages
sociaux aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'il ya 155 mille cheminots qui
se font partie de l'entreprise publique
sncf il y en a un peu près entre 5 et 8
milles qui font partie de différentes
petites ces entreprises privées
principalement au fret et donc elles ont
un droit social qui est bien plus bas
que les autres
donc nous on a une proposition de
réforme et l'alignement par le haut de
tous nos droits sociaux des 8000 en
direction des 155 milles et pas le
rabaissement le nivellement par le bas
les droits sociaux des cheminots de
l'entreprise publique historique sncf
vers le bas à versailles une
reconduction du mouvement a été votée en
assemblée générale pour ce jeudi
demain également les syndicats cheminots
se rendront au ministère des transports
à 14 heures où les représentants doivent
être reçus dans l'après midi et les
taxis étaient aussi mobilisés
aujourd'hui dans les différentes
capitales européennes ils protestaient
contre la concurrence des voitures de
tourisme avec chauffeur les vtc un
mouvement qui n'a pas eu d'incidence
dans les yvelines
même si les chauffeurs se disent
solidaires la présence des vtc dans le
département d'accès
2009 on compterait aujourd'hui 170
véhicules de tourisme avec chauffeur
inscrit à la chambre des métiers les
yvelines a comparé aux six cent soixante
dix licences de taxi mais on peut
appeler à la mobilisation pour la simple
raison c'est qu'en france nous avons vu
arriver les vtc depuis 2009
depuis la loi de modernisation du
tourisme et nous sommes précurseurs donc
nous avons déjà mené plusieurs plusieurs
actions dans ce sens là nous avons a
tiré à plusieurs reprises l'attention de
tous nos parlementaires et un médiateur
a été nommé nous secours ce qu'on
souhaite c'est que toute cette
réglementation soit bien encadré puisque
aujourd'hui n'importe qui rentre dans le
secteur du transport et vient faire de
la concurrence
qu'on le veuille ou pas et aujourd'hui
les vitesses le faut mais puisque en
plus de cela le fait qu'ils travaillent
avec ces nouvelles applications telles
que hubert a ayant là pour ne citer
qu'eux que cette entreprise américaine
qui viennent faire exactement la même la
même chose que fait le chauffeur taxi
les vtc aujourd'hui on le voit ils
stationnent en toute impunité sur la
voie publique en attente de course
or la tante de cours sur la voie
publique c'est une exclusivité qui
mondiale mais elle est donnée aux
chauffeurs de taxi le syndicat rappelle
que les taxis doivent payer une licence
coûteuse 115 mille euros en moyenne dans
le département pour le secteur de saint
quentin en yvelines et versailles ce
tarif grimpe jusqu'à 160 mille euros le
nombre de candidats est ailleurs en
forte diminution depuis et 2012
politique et finance le conseil
constitutionnel vient de donner raison
la ville de guyancourt dans son combat
contre le calcul du fonds de solidarité
de france font que les communes dites
plus riches doivent verser aux communes
les plus pauvres
conséquence la ville devrait gagner
quelques centaines de milliers d'euros
4,1 à taux patrick jacques de dixmude un
sourire et on le comprend le conseil
constitutionnel a donné raison au maire
de guyancourt n'abroge ans le
plafonnement qui réglementait le fonds
de solidarité de la région ile de france
dans les faits ce fonds est versée par
les communes dites les plus riches aux
communes les plus pauvres dans la
première mouture de 2009 la ville de
guyancourt n'avait pas à verser d'argent
au titre du caractère social de la
commune 2011 de nouvelles règles
s'appliquent
lui en cours devient contributrice à
hauteur de 2 millions d'euros soit 3 %
de son budget et soulève une inégalité
alors que les premières villes
contributrice obtiennent des
plafonnements les nouvelles communes
non c'est donc une injustice formidable
puisqu'on avait les villes les plus
riches déjà contributrice qui était
protégé le plafonnement c'est une
protection quand d'autres devaient payer
de plus en plus à guyancourt on a payé
jusqu'à 2 millions d'euros cet énorme
dans le budget d'une commune
la commune a lancé une procédure devant
le tribunal administratif poursuivie
jusqu'au conseil constitutionnel qui a
statué le 6 juin le conseil
constitutionnel a donné raison à
guyancourt
il a indiqué que ce ce principe de
plafonnement était anticonstitutionnelle
et qu'il doit être abrogée au 1er
janvier 2015 c'est donc une belle
victoire dans la mesure où le
plafonnement sera levé pour des communes
protéger ça veut dire que guyancourt
versera des centaines de milliers
d'euros en moins donc c'est c'est très
important
lui en cours poursuit un autre cheval de
bataille
faire évoluer le mode de calcul de ce
fonds basés sur les recettes des
entreprises en y intégrant les charges
sociales des communes dans ce combat lui
en cours associé à 14 autres villes de
l'île de france a obtenu une victoire à
20% des critères de calcul sont
dorénavant sociaux là encore il s'agit
de faire réduire la note un enjeu quand
on sait que les budgets des communes
sont de plus en plus serré et que les
dotations de l'état
de plus en plus réduite un appel à
souscription pour la rénovation de la
maison où vécut le leader du front
populaire léon blum vient d'être lancée
à jouy en josas viendra ensuite le temps
des travaux de rénovation est d'ici 2015
pour accueillir un plus large public
anthony rech et sébastien combes
c'est devant ses fenêtres que tous les
matins jeanne blum prenait son café
avant de travailler si elle rencontre
léon blum lors de la première guerre
mondiale
c'est à leur retour de déportation en
1945 qu'il décide de s'installer ici au
clos des messes léon blum y décède en
mais le leader du front populaire lui
laisse un souvenir indélébile
c'est une femme aussi de conviction gr
c'est une femme qui est devenu entre
guillemets jeudi de gauche sur le par
avec papa rencontre de léon blum puisque
c'était en fait elle même est une grande
bourgeoise sonçon son départ de vie si
je puis dire c'est une grande grande une
grande famille grande bourgeoise est
devenue l épouse et les convictions de
l'homme cadets nés cette maison classée
aux monuments historiques en 1983 est
aussi à l'image de l'homme léon blum un
humaniste sentimentale est profondément
amoureux d'une femme avec qui il se
maria dans le camp de concentration de
buchenwald
tout ça ça amène à découvrir l'homme
privé le grand amoureux parce que s'il
est présent dans les cinq dernières
années de sa vie ici il est enterré au
cimetière de juin josas c'est par amour
pour une femme et d'une femme
extraordinaire jeanne qui lui survivra
pendant 30 ans donc là le public va être
très surpris mais pour faire vivre la
mémoire du père des congés payés
l'endroit a besoin d'importants travaux
estimés à 1,2 million d'euros
la commune de jouy en josas lance donc
une campagne de mécénat populaire sous
l'égide de la fondation du patrimoine
qui permettra de financer l'installation
d'un nouveau parcours muséographique et
l'organisation de manifestations
régulières pour le grand public
on passe à l'entretien de ce journal
avec marie noëlle tarot conseillère
communautaire déléguée à la santé à
saint quentin en yvelines bonsoir est
également catherine chevalier bonsoir à
vous directrice par intérim de
l'institut de promotion et de la santé à
trappes aujourd'hui il vient de s'ouvrir
le forme de la santé à saint quentin en
yvelines 10ème anniversaire c'est à
l'espace 50 ans au centre commercial à
montigny le bretonneux des animations
sont proposées pilotes
par lee ps l'institut de promotion de la
santé de la communauté d'agglomération
basée elle attrape catherine chevalier
se sont tous vos partenaires qui sont
présents que trouve-t-on qu'est-ce qui
est proposée sur ce forum dont on vient
de voir quelques images
alors ce sont tous les partenaires santé
et santé environnement qui travaillent
avec nous au niveau de saint quentin en
yvelines
donc ce sont des renseignements il ya
aussi de dépistage qui sont proposés
alors oui voilà on a des dépistages par
exemple la chef prévention qui va faire
des trod test rapide d'orientation
diagnostique du sida ils font entre 200
et 300 tests par jour on a également
l'association française des diabétiques
qui fait des dépistages du diabète donc
qu'ils vont faire sur les quatre jours
environ 1000 tests et après on a
également d'autres partenaires qui sont
là pour présenter leurs structures et
toutes sont de droit commun et pour les
pour les habitants de saint quentin en
yvelines
le but c'est aussi de faire connaître
libé est structuré on tellement ensuite
de faire venir le public dans vos murs
attrape quelle est la fréquentation est
justement est-ce que ça a une incidence
se forme de la santé est ce que ça
permet de faire venir du monde ensuite
au lit ps alors en fait depuis dix ans
des filles disons qu'on organise ce
forum santé on a environ à 1500 passage
au niveau du forum santé pour les quatre
jours de présence et l'idée en fait
c'est de venir sur les lieux de vie et
lieu de vie de 10 ans continuaient pour
que pour se faire connaître et puis
ensuite pour qu'ils puissent venir nous
rencontrer nous lie ps et nos vingtaine
à nos vingt partenaires qu'on héberge au
niveau du ps donc oui partir oui à des
partenaires qui viennent faire des
habitants excusez moi qui viennent nous
rencontrer au niveau des passes et c'est
très intéressant pour ça vous fait
connaître de cette manière on
cette fréquentation de lits ps mais une
difficulté supplémentaire pour vous
puisque concernant les soins un français
sur deux qui dit avoir renoncé en raison
de leur coût c'est le résultat d'une
enquête qui a été publiée fin mai c'est
inquiétant aujourd'hui vous le constatez
aussi les gens viennent se renseigner
sur leur santé à l'eau les terres des
économies les gens ne viennent pas
forcément moins se renseigner par contre
en fait on distingue deux types de
population les personnes qui sont très
très éloigné de la santé type sdf etc et
les personnes qui sont juste au dessus
du seuil de la cmu qui eux ne
ne bénéficient pas de mutuelle de
complémentaire santé et qu'ils renoncent
aux soins
donc on met en place tout un tout un
travail pour prioriser auprès de ces
personnes auraient le tarot peut-être
responsables de la santé pour la
communauté d'agglomération vous êtes
inquiète aussi de ce constat de voir que
les gens ne s'inquiètent plus de leur
santé
et c'est une des missions de
l'agglomération aussi que de l'ours
d'offrir des outils et forcément
accessible bien entendu c'est
effectivement un des soucis que nous
allons avoir et qui risque d'augmenter
puisque malgré tout il ya une précarité
qui quand même est assez importante même
si sur l'ensemble de la communauté
d'agglomération nous n'avons pas que des
soucis de ce type mais c'est vrai que
pour nous c'est quand même très très
important d'apporter cette à des rôles
justement de lits ps de faire de la
prévention et de partir du principe que
la santé ce n'est pas que je suis malade
ou je suis infirme mais au contraire je
vis dans un environnement satisfaisant
donc c'est pour ça que sur le forum il y
avait cet axe sur l'eau la pollution de
l'eau le fait d'être attentif et de
préserver justement 7,7 éléments
indispensables à la vie
donc c'est tout ce travail aussi de
partenariat que l'on fait ça nous paraît
très important
c'est aussi un des rôles de l'ip et sc2
d'aider les personnes qui sont en
précarité c'est en particulier dans le
contrat local de santé qui a été signé
en 2011 avec
-les agences régionales de santé et sur
laquelle effectivement nous allons
travailler
bon c'est vrai que là je découvre un
petit peu ça fait un mois que je viens
de prendre cette responsabilité
mais c'est vrai que tout le travail de
partenariat avec nous avons donc une
vingtaine de résidents partenaires
associatifs qui accompagne tout à
l'heure on parlait de précarité de
personnes qui ne sont plus soignés il ya
des médecins bénévoles qui viennent ali
ps régulièrement il ya lieu d coup de
jeune il ya énormément d'action qui sont
développés donc pour le moment moi je
prends je découvre un petit peu toutes
ces actions même si étant déjà délégué
communautaire dans le mandat précédent
j'avais une notion un petit peu mais là
je le prends vraiment est donc pour le
moment où mon objectif c'est de
continuer toutes les actions qui sont en
direction de tous ces publics que ce
soit de la petite enfance jusqu'à la
personne âgée parce que faut prendre en
compte toute la population et à tous les
âges y avait toutes les difficultés ou
tout tout la bonne santé pourquoi pas
aussi parce que c'est important de
montrer que l'on peut être aussi en
bonne santé et que en étant en bonne
santé il faut justement prévenir et
essayons de ne pas être seulement là
pour guérir et ce n'est pas forcément
notre premier objectif
on va reparler un peu plus en détails de
votre politique de santé pour
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour ce nouveau mandat qui
s'ouvre avec cette précision
vous l'avez déjà rappelé il ya eu un
changement de majorité au sein des
équipes de l'agglomération ce qui
explique que vous découvrez différemment
les dossiers cette fois-ci auparavant
micro-trottoir notre question du jour
vous en avez l'habitude
ce soir nous vous avons demandé comment
vous preniez soin de votre santé au
quotidien ça rejoint un petit peu ce que
vous disiez tout à la malnutrition
mme alimentation et je fais du sport
régulièrement moi j'essaie j'essaie de
manger équilibré j'essaye de faire du
sport à une alimentation équilibrée et
de l'activité sportive
j'essaye de prendre soin de moi et si
j'ai certes un symptôme de consulter
médecin généraliste d'abord je marche je
fais un peu de gym tous les soirs enfin
j'ai autrement je fais attention à ce
que je mange
à ce que je bois sans tige marche tous
les jours - au moins huit kilomètres par
jour
un bilan sanguin tous les ans et y voilà
je mange bien je fais un petit peu de
sport et puis et puis vint chez en sorte
de positiver les choses
catherine chevalier pour pour li ps sont
les bonnes attitudes à adopter
vous conseillez aussi soyons pas comme
ça prévient en tout cas oui j'aime bien
parce qu'en fait la plupart des
personnes parlent de santé au sens
positif au sens prévention
donc ça rejoint
ce qu'on fait au niveau de l'ip s en
termes de santé essayez de
de prendre soin de soi et des autres
tels que la définition de laurie mais sa
santé
enfin le bien-être ce n'est pas
seulement l'absence de maladie mais
également le bien-être physique morale
etc
il ya ce forum santé actuellement à
l'espace saint quentin à montigny le
bretonneux et qui va se dérouler
jusqu'au 14 juin c'est bien ça que je me
trompe dans les dates si vous souhaitez
y participer j'en viens à la politique
santé de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines vous nous le dites
je vous pose la question plus
directement l'une des priorités
affichées par le nouveau président de
l'agglomération michel laugier c'est
l'économie avec un premier adjoint qui a
été nommé à ces à cette fonction la
santé reste malgré tout une priorité
ah oui là c'est pas un poste seront
faites des économies justement le nom de
toute façon je vais défendre fortement
ce poste m bien entendu mais je pense
que c'est très important parce que ça a
un impact surtout la santé ces impacts
sur la vie au quotidien ses impacts sur
éventuellement le travail donc si vous
êtes en bonne santé pour aller au
travail c'est quand même plus facile
donc les personnes la définissait bien
je suis en bonne santé je fais attention
éventuellement je fais quelques analyses
et où je fais du sport et je me sens
bien à partir du moment où on se sent
bien la santé c'est un plus quand même
donc ce n'est quand même pas il n'y aura
pas un objectif de réduction budgétaire
et je pense que toutes les actions qui
sont développés alors peut-être
qu'effectivement il y aura des choses à
transformer de mutualiser peut-être nous
avons des partenaires qui sont très
compétents des associations qui sont
vraiment proches des habitants et on est
tous les sens et dossier vous allez voit
l'arbitré un petit peu tout cinq ans
pour la rentrée alors pour la rentrée
oui j'ai mes devoirs de vacances en fait
donc je vais pouvoir travailler sur sur
ces dossiers et puis après nous allons
proposer une ligne
effectivement pour les années à venir
mais déjà beaucoup de choses qui se font
en partenariat et ça c'est très
important
nous allons continuer à les développer
merci à toutes les deux être passé sur
ce plateau le forum santé jusqu'au 14
juin si vous venez
nous rejoindre voici le reportage de
yolaine thorez qui a été tourné
aujourd'hui sur le forum santé justement
petit aperçu la dixième édition du forum
santé est lancé jusqu'au samedi 14 juin
une vingtaine d'acteurs de la santé vous
accueillent gratuitement au centre
commercial espace saint quentin
parmi les participants l'association
française des diabétiques des yvelines
elle propose aux passants des dépistages
de glycémie gratuit ça coûte rien comme
ça comme j'ai jamais fait c'est juste du
mouvement gaulliste et gratuit j'ai dit
je vais ici les parages est ici le mot
dit que c'était bon ou d'activé ont
assuré parallèlement donc là on m'a dit
que c'est bon ça me rassure il suffit
d'une goutte pour savoir la quantité de
sucre contenu dans le sang de la
personne
lors de cette première journée les
bénévoles ont dépisté quelques glycémie
élevée
nous avons conseillé aux personnes de
s'orienter très rapidement vers leur
médecin traitant pour pouvoir avoir un
examen plus approfondi entre autres une
glycémie à jeun
à quelques mètres de là le pôle jeunesse
de la ville de montigny le bretonneux
propose notamment deux outils les
lunettes alcool et le testeur de
monoxyde de carbone
le premier permet de se rendre compte de
la vision d'une personne alcoolisée
tandis que le deuxième quart mais de
vérifier si l'on est dépendant ou non au
tabac en soufflant dans l'embout
l'appareil détecte la quantité de
monoxyde de carbone et en a qui se
pensaient pas trop dépendants et qui
finalement était
borderline on va dire donc ça permet une
petite prise de conscience et aussi avec
les lunettes de se rendre compte que
on se croit toujours maître de la
situation mais en fait on a des réflexes
plus lent on a une vision très très
restreinte donc tout ça ils s'en rendent
bien compte avec ces outils là vous avez
jusqu'à samedi 19h pour profiter de ces
tests gratuits et vous informer auprès
des autres participants le forum est
organisé par l'institut de promotion de
la santé de trappes
on quitte le domaine médical pour celui
du cheval dimanche pour sa 13e édition
le trophée vert a fait escale à
rambouillet sixième étape de ce tournoi
au cours duquel trois prix sont disputés
et cette année une nouveauté une
nouvelle catégorie réservée aux poneys
mathilde capbern est clair combien sur
la piste de l'hippodrome de rambouillet
une soixantaine de trotteurs se
disputent la 6e étape du trophée vert
championnat incontournable du trot
attelé
cette journée devient pour certains un
tournant dans leur parcours de driver
c'est ma dernière course
ma planche et je passe professionnel en
tant qu'apprenti faut gagner 50 courses
et une fois qu'on a gagné 50 course va
on n'a plus retrouvé en affronter la
compétition mise en place en 2001 est un
circuit national sur quatorze étapes
sa particularité toutes les pistes se
conjugue au vert rambouillet n'a pas été
choisi au hasard par le professionnel je
voyais les pistes en herbe disparaître
au fur et à mesure au profit de la
création de piste en dur et les points
de vue professionnel c'était une erreur
monumentale parce que tout le monde
voulait une piste en dur comme charte
comme laval comme à caen c'est une
comptine piste est très utile
quand il ya beaucoup de rythme c'est
facile de revenir c'est ce qui s'est
passé il y avait beaucoup de trains donc
ça avantage des shows qui rendent à
distance au fil du temps le trophée vert
s'était étoffée nouveautés 2014 la
course de poneys un système de promotion
qui commence dès le plus jeune âge cela
ne les empêche pas de se comporter comme
de vrais professionnels
cela entraîne deux fois par semaine
l'éveil de course et tous au bas je le
laisse tranquille et leurs mains après
on prépare tout doucement et puis on
parcourt prochaine étape du trophée vert
en champagne ardenne à montier-en-der
sur la finale 80 mille euros seront à se
partager entre les sept premiers trotter
fin de journal rendez vous jeudi 18h en
direct pour une nouvelle édition pour
faire le point sur l'actualité locale
première diffusion à 19h et le replay
sur notre site internet
bonne soirée
où